Transcription: Manon Armenoult
Relecteur: eric vautier
Bonjour à tous. Bonjour Marseille.
C’est une première pour moi d’être ici.
J’ai 38 ans,
je m’appelle Cindy Dauvin-Cariou,
nom de jeune fille que j’aime conserver.
J’ai deux enfants en bas âge
et je suis ravie d’être avec vous.
Je vais vous parler d’un thème
qui me tient très à cœur
et qui me fait vivre au quotidien.
L’avenir appartient
aux entreprises bienveillantes.
Est-ce que la bienveillance vous parle ?
Au quotidien, dans le travail,
avec votre famille, vos amis ?
Est-ce si facile à mettre en place ? Non.
Pour revenir un petit peu à mes origines,
je suis fille de boucher
d’un petit patelin de Bretagne
de 2000 habitants qui ne fait pas rêver
J'avais un père boucher.
Les cours du soir chez moi,
c’était les devoirs vite faits
puis on va à la boucherie
apprendre à cuisiner
pour faire en sorte
de savoir tenir une boucherie.
Et j’ai eu une révélation.
J’ai aimé l’Homme avec un grand H.
J’ai aimé ce contact humain
de venir chercher sa tranche de jambon,
une fois, deux fois, trois fois par jour
pour avoir ce petit mot réconfortant
ou cette petite anecdote à me raconter
sur leur chien, leur chat, peu importe.
Puis une chose puissante s’est produite
et je me suis dit :
« Je ne sais pas quoi faire de ma vie.
La boucherie,
ce n’est pas sexy quand même,
n’exagérons rien. »
En toute logique, je me suis tournée
vers des études de commerce.
Le côté international me plaisait bien
parce que du coup :
« Au revoir la Bretagne ».
Je me voyais me balader à Miami. Partout.
Cela ne s’est pas vraiment passé comme ça.
Donc me voilà à 20 ans,
avec un diplôme de commerce international.
J’ai dit à mon père : « On fait quoi ?
- Exporte des galettes, ma fille ! »
Bon, on va peut-être réussir à faire mieux
qu’exporter des galettes bretonnes.
Donc je suis partie à la capitale.
Oui, on disait « La capitale » à l’époque.
Je sais, cela fait un peu vieille France
mais c’était « La capitale ».
Donc me voilà avec mes deux valises.
Et puis des CV dans les mains
en me disant : « Je vais faire quoi ? »
Bon, les agences d’intérim, c’est pas mal.
J’ai un diplôme, je suis bouchère,
ce n’est pas trop mal.
Bouchère en intérim.
Puis j’ai rencontré une première société
qui m’a fait confiance
et je suis devenue assistante commerciale.
J’arrivais toujours avec la pêche
car je suis née dans cette bienveillance,
cette grande famille.
C’était mes valeurs.
Donc c’était facile pour moi
d’arriver avec la pêche.
Mais je voyais mes collègues -
surtout les commerciaux -
qui faisaient la tête,
il y avait toujours des problèmes,
rien n’était facile.
(Soupir) « Ça n’a pas l’air fun de bosser.
C’était mieux à la boucherie ».
Mais hors de question d’y retourner.
Puis j’ai eu de la chance,
j’ai beaucoup travaillé
et trois ans après, j’ai eu une promotion.
Je suis devenue directrice commerciale.
À 23 ans, c'était plutôt pas mal.
Mais surtout, on m’a donné des Hommes,
« avec un grand H », à manager.
Mais je les voyais venir le lundi matin,
toujours à faire la tête
et jamais contents.
Je me suis dit que je ne pouvais pas
laisser les choses comme ça.
Alors j’ai un peu réfléchi,
je n’ai rien réinventé.
Je passais le lundi matin
devant chez mon primeur,
je récupérais quelques fruits.
Des chocolatines aussi,
comme on dit à Bordeaux.
On se faisait des petits déj’ informels,
on discutait de notre week-end.
Je voyais que la sauce prenait.
Et pourquoi ?
Combien d’entre vous
êtes camarades, collègues ?
Vous connaissez-vous vraiment ?
Eh bien non.
Et dans ce cas-là, on ne peut pas être
bons ensemble et faire une équipe.
Puis, sur un coup de folie -
cela m’arrive assez régulièrement -
j’ai dit :
« On a des voitures de fonction ?
- Oui.
- Partons en séminaire.
- Le boss n’est pas d’accord
et on n’a pas de sous.
- Ne vous inquiétez pas,
cela va bien se passer. »
J’avais la chance
de bien gagner ma vie à Paris,
du coup, on a fait
une location sur un site,
on a choisi une maison au Cap-Ferret
et on est tous partis là-bas.
« Mais on va partager le même lit ?
- Non, juste la même chambre.
- Pas de restaurant ?
- Non, on va apprendre
à cuisiner ensemble.
- Ah bon ?
- Et on va faire des activités
parce qu’il faut apprendre à se connaître.
- On va faire quoi ?
- Vous allez voir. »
Je n’ai rien fait d’incroyable.
Je leur ai fait manger
des vers de terre pour rigoler.
On a fait du tir à la corde.
Néanmoins, pendant trois jours,
on a vécu ensemble
et on a appris à se connaître.
Trois mois après,
mon directeur Cyril m’appelle :
« - Tu peux venir ?
- Qu’est-ce qu’il y a ?
- Tu as vu le dernier trimestre ?
- Oui, je crois.
Les chiffres sont très bons.
- Et tu expliques ça comment ?
Tu as fait quoi ?
- Tu ne te souviens pas ?
On a créé un truc de malade au séminaire.
- Ah non, mais Cindy, c’est fini ça.
Depuis quand les séminaires provoquent
une hausse de 30% du chiffre ?
- Car le capital humain
est ce qu’il y a de plus important.
- Ce ne sont pas mes valeurs.
Investir sur l’homme ?
Tu as vu vos salaires ? Vos commissions ?
Non, on ne va pas faire ça. »
J’ai 25 ans et je me dis « Mince,
cela ne va pas avec mes valeurs,
cela ne va pas avec ce que j’ai appris,
ni avec mon éducation. »
Alors j’ai démissionné.
Et pourtant, le salaire était beau.
Je me suis demandé ce que j’allais faire.
J’ai 25 ans, je démissionne
d’un poste avec plusieurs zéros.
Qu’est-ce que je fais ?
En fait, les Anglo-Saxons
m’ont toujours passionnée.
Parce que je trouvais cela chouette,
les afterworks à 17 h.
En France, il y a un petit problème.
À 16 h, quand tu pars :
« Ah mais tu as pris ton après-midi ?
- Non, je vais juste chercher mes enfants.
Je travaille depuis 8h ce matin,
pas de problème. »
Alors qu’aux États-Unis ou en Angleterre,
quand tu fais un afterwork,
tu continues à parler de ton boulot.
Tu te donnes des tips :
« Comment tu as réussi ce dossier ?
Et toi alors ? »
Il se passe quelque chose !
J’ai adoré ça.
J’ai adoré ce management horizontal
où on n’est pas là pour faire des réunions
et rester des heures assis,
à écouter sans même savoir pourquoi,
mais où on vous demande d’être là.
Et donc, un an après,
je suis revenue au taquet à Paris.
Et j’ai trouvé un poste
où j’ai expliqué tout ça.
Puis on m’a regardée et on m’a dit :
« Ah ouais, mais il n’y a pas de budget. »
Donc, j’ai fait avec les moyens du bord,
même si ce n’était pas grand-chose.
Puis à 30 ans,
j’ai eu la promotion de mes rêves
qui était de gérer une filiale à New York.
Je regardais « Sex and the City »
et je me voyais devant Central Park,
gérer 50 bonhommes.
Je me suis dit : « Ça va être génial. »
Entre temps, je suis tombée amoureuse
et j’ai suivi l’amour de ma vie
à Bordeaux.
Donc, arrivée à 30 ans là-bas,
pleine de conviction.
Mais les boîtes étaient
encore pires qu’à Paris.
Je me suis dit : « Tu es mal barrée.
Qu’est-ce que tu vas faire ? »
Alors entre temps, j’ai fait un bébé.
Super belle chose.
Deuxièmement, j’ai été aux prud’hommes.
Troisièmement, harcèlement moral.
et en quatrième,
des propos très très sexistes,
pour ne pas dire autre chose.
Et là j’ai dit : (souffle)
« Vous savez quoi ? J’en ai marre.
Je vais acheter mon paperboard
à 10 € sur le Bon Coin
et je vais créer la boîte de mes rêves,
celle que j’aurais voulue,
et je vais défendre
le bien-être au travail. »
Mon mari m’a regardée et m’a dit :
« Défenseur du bien-être au travail ?
C’est-à-dire ? »
Eh bien, cela porte un nom.
La plupart, ici, ne le sait peut-être pas,
mais on va vous interroger.
J’ai créé une société dans la QVT.
Est-ce que cela vous parle ?
Bravo ! Mais vous n’êtes
pas beaucoup à l’avoir dit.
La QVT, « Qualité de vie au travail ».
Pourtant aujourd’hui,
cela existe très fort
Mais ce n’est pas assez mis en place.
Donc qu’est-ce que c’est la QVT ?
C’est très simple,
c’est un sentiment de bien-être
là où vous êtes, dans votre entreprise,
vos conditions de travail,
la bienveillance qu’on a envers vous,
les points réguliers, si vous êtes formé.
Il y a un mot dont on entend parler.
Connaissez-vous le « bore-out » ?
Cela vous parle ?
C’est l’ennui au travail.
On oublie que l’on a
des budgets de formation.
On oublie de prendre soin de vous
et de vous former.
Mais après cinq ans au même poste,
vous avez envie d’évoluer,
vous avez envie d’aller plus loin.
C’est cela aussi les bilans de compétences
et toujours d’aller plus loin.
Du coup, j’ai regardé des chiffres,
je me suis intéressée,
et je me suis dit : « Mince,
il y a des pays qui sont très forts :
la Finlande, les pays nordiques,
qui ont vraiment compris ce qu’est la QVT.
Mais nous, en France,
on est en 23ᵉ position. »
Je me suis demandé
si j’étais prête pour ce combat.
Parce que c’est un combat quotidien.
De toute façon,
comme je ne trouve pas de boîte,
autant essayer de la créer
et j’ai eu la bonne idée de faire cela
six mois avant le Covid.
Quand on sait
que tout repose sur l’être humain
et qu’il n’y en a pas dans les sociétés
qui sont en télétravail,
les choses se compliquent.
Mais on ne se démonte pas,
on est têtue, on est bretonne,
et on y va !
Donc aujourd’hui, tout le monde dit :
« Mais moi j’ai de la QVT à Paris.
J’ai des poufs de couleurs. »
(Applaudit) Trop chouette !
« Moi j’ai le baby-foot dernier cri,
mon boss m’a mis ça,
ça m’a donné deux ans de survie
dans la boîte. »
Ah d’accord, on est loin,
on est loin, on est loin.
Au moins, à Bordeaux,
il n’y avait ni baby-foot, ni poufs,
donc j’avais un peu de marge.
Il n’y avait rien en fait.
Donc je partais de zéro,
avec pas grand-chose,
des convictions et des chiffres.
Et c’est ce dont je voudrais vous parler.
Parce qu’il y a des chiffres affolants
mais quand on n’est pas dedans,
on ne peut pas s’en rendre compte.
Il y a trois thèmes que je vais aborder :
Les « RPS » - qui devraient vous parler -
les « risques psycho-sociaux ».
Puis la génération passionnante
des millennials.
Et enfin, la marque employeur.
Le premier, ce sont les « RPS ».
Est-ce que vous savez,
combien de personnes en 2021,
ont été en burn out ?
Plus de 25 millions.
Je suis sûre que dans la salle,
tous autant que vous êtes,
vous connaissez quelqu’un, un parent,
un proche, qui a fait un burn out.
Le pire, c’est que l’on pense
pouvoir être épargné,
car on a du caractère
et qu’on ne veut pas que cela nous touche.
Mais c’est faux. Ça arrive d’un coup
et on prend des années à s’en remettre.
Ce que le chef d’entreprise
n’a toujours pas saisi.
« Mais mes équipes vont bien.
Elles ont le baby-foot,
elles ne font pas de burn-out. »
Et en vérité,
cela coûte un peu d’argent à l’État.
« L’État, on s’en fiche un peu. »
Et non car l’État,
c’est un peu nous quand même.
107 milliardsd’euros,
c’est ce que coûte chaque année
l’absentéisme et donc,
le mal-être au travail.
107 milliardsd’euros quand même.
Mais ce n’est pas assez parlant
donc voici un chiffre par collaborateur
car vous allez tous le devenir un jour :
le mal-être au travail coûte 13 340€.
Je n’ai rien inventé,
c’est l’indice du bien-être au travail
de 2021.
Donc si on imagine un chef d’entreprise
bienveillant et intéressant se dire :
« Et si je mettais 10 000€ par an,
pour que mes collaborateurs
soient bien au travail ? »
Ce serait pas mal.
Mais même avec la crise sanitaire
que l’on a vécue,
on s’était battu pour le télétravail
et en fait, en France,
on a été assez mauvais.
Il a fallu que cette crise arrive
et à ce moment-là,
on n’a pas eu le choix et les équipes
ont été performantes et à la hauteur.
La question que j’ai envie
de vous poser cet après-midi, c’est :
Est-ce qu’il va falloir une énième crise ?
Qu’est-ce qu’il va falloir faire pour
que le chef d’entreprise veuille prendre
soin de vous et de ses collaborateurs
et donc d’avoir
une meilleure productivité.
Car il ne va pas investir sur vous,
s’il n’y a rien qui se passe derrière.
On est bien d'accord.
J’en arrive à ces millenials
qui me passionnent totalement.
Pourquoi ?
Parce qu’ils se fichent du salaire.
Vous savez quoi ?
Le salaire arrive en troisième position.
Le meilleur package du monde ?
Ce n’est même pas intéressant.
Que veulent-ils ?
Les missions.
Le poste, les valeurs de la société.
Aujourd’hui pour les séduire,
et je peux vous en parler parce qu’il y a
quinze millenials dans ma société.
Il y en a certains
que j’ai voulu avoir sans succès,
puisqu’on ne peut pas,
parce que c’est la vie.
Mais en tout cas,
c’est passionnant de se dire
que c’est grâce à cette génération
que l’on ne va pas pouvoir accepter
toutes les conditions de travail.
Est-ce qu’un ticket restaurant est assez
avec un SMIC et quelques commissions ?
Pas du tout.
Sans les gens comme vous aujourd’hui,
on ne va pas y arriver.
Et ça, c'est dur.
Et ceux qui sont parents
comme c’est le cas pour moi,
se demandent comme cela sera dans 20 ans
si aujourd’hui, on ne fait rien pour cela.
Donc cette génération est fabuleuse
et pourquoi cela ?
Parce qu’avant, on ne se renseignait pas
sur la société dans laquelle on allait.
On voyait le poste, on se disait :
« Ça a l’air sympa, le package aussi. »
Aujourd’hui vous êtes plus de deux tiers
à vous renseigner sur les réseaux
pour voir si une boîte vaut le coup.
Si elle bosse sur sa responsabilité
sociétale des entreprises,
Si elle prend soin de ses collaborateurs,
si elle met en place des actions
comme du team building,
si elle prend soin de vous, clairement.
Du coup, les boîtes paniquent
et m’appellent :
« Je suis un peu moyen
sur la marque employeur. »
Ah c’est sûr, tu ne fais rien
pour tes collaborateurs,
on ne peut pas montrer du fake.
On arrive donc à notre dernier thème,
la marque employeur.
Et cette marque employeur,
ce qui est assez génial
avec toutes les boîtes que j’accompagne -
j’en ai à peu près une cinquantaine -
c’est qu’il y a un chiffre assez fabuleux.
C’est OpinionWay qui l’a sorti.
Il y a plus de 235%
de retour sur investissement
lorsque vous mettez en place
une démarche QVT dans une société.
En prenant soin de vous,
la société gagne de l’argent.
Tout le monde est gagnant.
Donc pourquoi, un chef d’entreprise
est capable de mettre des millions
sur des contrats de maintenance,
des photocopieurs, du leasing, etc.,
et ne pas penser à l’Homme,
son capital le plus précieux.
Donc c’est ma bataille,
avec mes équipes au quotidien,
de démocratiser et d’initier cela,
et je vous assure
que c’est un gros combat.
J’ai une dernière anecdote.
Un chef d’entreprise bordelais
m’appelle et me dit :
« Cindy, je crois que cela ne va pas.
Mes collaborateurs sont un peu burn out,
un peu déprimés.
Vous pensez pouvoir m’aider ?
- Ok, prenons rendez-vous. »
Et là, il me sort son chéquier.
« Mais on n’a pas encore
parlé de la méthode.
- Si, ils vont mal,
ça coûte de l’argent, combien il faut ?
- Non, cela ne marche pas
comme ça dans la vie.
Je vais vous expliquer. »
Qu’est-ce qu’on fait chez XXL Happyness ?
Un diagnostic.
On va étudier les besoins
de vos collaborateurs,
et ce que vous avez envie de leur donner.
On ne peut pas décider
comme ça au doigt mouillé,
« Il leur faudrait des cours de sport.
Il leur faudrait de la relaxation. »
Et là, il me dit :
« Mais on ne va pas interroger
les collaborateurs !
- Ah bon, pourquoi ?
- Ils ont déjà un salaire.
Ils ne sont pas malheureux chez moi.
Mais pourquoi demanderait-on leur avis ?
- Ah ouais mince,
ça va être compliqué là, Monsieur.
Ce n’est pas dans la démarche
d’XXL Happyness.
- D’accord. Qu’est-ce qu’on fait alors ?
- Bah, on ne fait rien. »
Et je n’ai pas pris le chèque.
Et pourtant il était beau !
Mais on avance, ce n’est pas grave.
Ce qu’il faut savoir, c’est qu’en 2030,
il y aura plus de 40% d’indépendants.
Imaginez 40% d'indépendants.
Pourquoi ?
Car les entreprises n’arrivent plus
à faire rêver les collaborateurs.
Et vous ici, allez planter des graines,
dans chaque société
car vous n’allez pas accepter
les conditions de travail.
Vous avez envie et besoin d’autre chose
pour être bien au travail.
Si en tant que défenseur
du bien-être au travail, avec mes équipes,
je ne peux pas compter sur vous,
la génération de demain,
comment je fais ?
Alors je n’ai pas le choix
que de vous demander un peu d’aide
parce que la qualité de vie au travail
est un vrai métier, mais peu démocratisé.
Aujourd’hui, la formation est devenue
quelque chose d’essentiel.
On a des budgets pour cela.
LA QVT ? Pas du tout.
On met des contrats de maintenance
qui sont indécents
sur des ordinateurs, du leasing.
On refait des flottes
de voitures électriques.
Mais la QVT, on l’oublie.
Et pourquoi ?
Parce que cela n’existe pas assez.
Donc j’ai besoin de ces petites graines
que vous allez mettre partout
et je souhaite finir
avec une citation d’Henry Ford :
« Les deux plus belles choses
qui ne se voient pas au bilan
sont sa réputation et ses hommes. »
Merci à tous et à toutes.
Très belle journée.
(Applaudissements)